[Música]
en medio de la cuenta regresiva para la
toma de posesión del nuevo presidente de
eeuu se mantiene la extrema seguridad en
washington el mandatario electo joe
biden dio un emotivo mensaje antes de
partir hacia la capital del país
mientras que el presidente saliente
donald trump se despidió a través de un
mensaje en youtube tenemos los detalles
desde washington
y empezó el proceso de confirmación de
los nominados del gabinete de
administración
hayden jarvis con la primera audiencia
en el senado pese a que todavía falta la
aprobación de la cámara alta el
presidente electo ha conformado uno de
los gabinetes más diversos en la
historia del país los tenemos los
detalles
y mientras avanza la vacunación en
brásil los hospitales de la ciudad
amazónica de manaos no tienen oxígeno
para atender a los pacientes con kobe 19
lo que ha aumentado la ya complicada
crisis sanitaria la ciudad de cercanas
se han blindado para evitar una
situación similar
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález comenzamos con lo último en
torno a la toma de posición del
presidente electo de eeuu joe biden que
tendrá lugar mañana
washington la capital del país sigue
fuertemente custodiada por 25 mil
integrantes de la guardia nacional el
centro de la ciudad se ha convertido en
una zona fortificada con cierres de
calles de estaciones de metro controles
militares y también bloques de cemento
para desviar el tráfico de otra parte el
presidente electo joe biden dio unas
emotivas declaraciones al momento de
partida hacia la ciudad de washington a
su turno también el presidente saliente
donald trump destacó varios logros de su
mandato a través de un mensaje en
youtube
travers broadway hace 12 años estaba
esperando en la estación de tren de
wilmington a que un hombre negro me
recogiera de camino a washington donde
juramos como presidente y vicepresidente
de los eeuu de américa
y aquí estamos hoy mi familia y yo a
punto de regresar a washington
para encontrarnos con una mujer negra de
ascendencia del sur de asia y juntos
tomar posesión como presidente y
vicepresidenta de los eeuu
y todos los estadounidenses estábamos
aterrorizados por el asalto a nuestro
capitolio la violencia política es un
ataque en todo lo que celebramos como
estadounidenses y nunca será tolerado
ahora más que nunca debemos unirnos en
nuestros valores compartidos y
levantarnos del partidismo y alcanzar
nuestro destino
y vamos a conocer más detalles de otros
hechos ocurridos hoy en la ciudad de
washington la capital de estados unidos
allí está cristóbal vázquez nuestro
corresponsal buenas noches cristóbal
también destacado en la jornada de hoy
en la detención de ese grupo de guardias
de la guardia nacional que fueron
retirados porque aparentemente están
relacionados con grupos de extrema
derecha que se sabe hasta el momento
fueron 12 en total 12 guardias
nacionales que han sido retirados de sus
prisiones para el evento de inauguración
de mañana entre estos 12 dos fueron
retirados por mensajes y comentarios
inapropiados que el fbi identificó los
otros diez fueron retirados por
cuestionamiento por comportamiento
cuestionable y lo que está haciendo el
fbi precisamente es una revisión en este
momento está pasando esta revisión de
los cerca de 25.000 hombres de la
guardia personal que están aquí en
washington para evitar una amenaza
interna y es que se han venido rumorando
varios medios de comunicación local han
dicho que pues hubo complicidad por
parte de la fuerza pública durante los
ataques del 6 de enero y por eso se
quiere evitar una incidente más mañana
el día de posición de jobvite gracias
cristal por este reporte desde la
capital de eeuu con la alternancia en el
poder y también la llegada de los
demócratas yobái de ni kamala harris a
la casa blanca también podría significar
un cambio hacia
un gabinete diverso pocas veces antes
visto en la historia de eeuu con
afroamericanos latinos asiáticos nativos
también y transexuales ocupando por
primera vez los más altos cargos en el
gobierno el gabinete de esta nueva
administración busca representar toda la
diversidad étnica y también social de la
unión americana la mayoría de los
nombramientos aún debe ser confirmada
por el senado que comenzó las audiencias
el día de hoy
un gabinete que se parezca a eeuu
durante su campaña presidencial esa fue
la promesa que hizo joe biden y hoy dice
haberla cumplido el gabinete tiene más
de una docena de nombramientos
históricos incluida la primera mujer
secretaria del tesoro el primer
secretario de defensa afroamericanos el
primer miembro del gabinete abiertamente
homosexual y la primera secretaria del
gabinete que es una nativo americana
dentro de la cerca de 30 personas que
viven ha elegido y los 50 nombramientos
de alto nivel que ha hecho está el
nombre de dave holland la primera nativa
en ser elegida como representante a la
cámara y que ahora estará a cargo del
departamento que determina la política
para los recursos naturales y las
tierras tribales
me enorgullece estar aquí en las tierras
ancestrales de la nación tribal de la
cnop y ella es una de las decenas de
mujeres que podrían ocupar los más altos
cargos de eeuu
este será el primer gabinete que está
compuesto equitativamente por tantas
mujeres como hombres de cama
entre ellos están janet yellen nominada
para ser secretaria de tesoros y
vírgenes para la dirección de
inteligencia nacional y linda thomas
winfield como embajadora ante la onu
los afroamericanos y los latinos también
tienen un puesto relevante en la nueva
conformación de la casa blanca
este será el primer gabinete con una
mayoría de personas de color de xcán
dos de los secretarios podrían ser
afroamericanos si el senado confirma al
general retirado yo
austin en la cartera de defensa y a
murcia food en vivienda
además michael reagan estaría al frente
de la agencia de protección ambiental
epa la institución más importante sobre
medioambiente
la participación latina sería por cuenta
de alejandro mayorkas un cubano
americano cuya familia se fue de cuba
tras la revolución de los castros y
quien ahora dirigiría el departamento de
seguridad nacional también está javier
becerra quien sería el primer latino
como secretario de salud
otros nominados se caracterizan por
haber trabajado en organizaciones
sociales un gran contraste frente al
gabinete que tuvo tonal trump donde
predominaba en los hombres blancos y con
poca experiencia en la casa blanca
y cambiamos de tema mientras comienzan a
llegar las dosis de vacunas contra el
kobe 19 y también avanza el plan de
inmunización en brásil en la capital del
estado de amazonas la ciudad de manaus
escasea el oxígeno en los hospitales lo
que dificulta la atención para los
pacientes que padecen coronavirus
a pocos kilómetros del caos de la
megalópolis amazónica la pequeña ciudad
de iranduba parece muy tranquila aquí
las autoridades han impuesto un toque de
queda durante una semana desde las 2 de
la tarde las calles están desiertas el
hospital de la ciudad tiene el 90% de
sus camas ocupadas la situación es seria
para esta familia de comerciantes no
tenemos una unidad de cuidados
intensivos si la teníamos pero único
funcionó sin ninguna unidad de cuidados
intensivos y con más de 3400 positivos y
60 decesos en pocas semanas iranduba
hace todo para que funcione el
transporte público a managua está
prohibido la patrulla solo tiene una
solución tolerancia a cero
tienes que ir a casa hoy te doy un
simple consejo pero si vuelve a suceder
serás detenido
por favor ponte esta mascarilla aquí
a los que nunca han padecido la
enfermedad en casa piensan que es una
broma que no hay proliferación del virus
así que es un trabajo duro pero sobre
todo educativo
el capitán no tiene intención de que su
ciudad sea contagiada por manaos
con todos los medios que tienen en
manaos están en una situación complicada
así que estamos haciendo todo lo posible
para evitar llegar a este nivel iranduba
ha logrado asegurar un valioso
suministro de oxígeno en manaus frente a
esta empresa privada a cientos de
parientes enfermos esperan durante horas
un recambio del preciado gas
miren los que puedan dejar sus tanques
háganlo por qué no podemos llenarlos
hasta mañana por la tarde una triste
rutina para el dueño desearía no tener
que llorar con todo el mundo
queriendo querida mía hoy no hay enemigo
amigo pues rico o pobre soy el proveedor
oficial del estado vecino manaos ha
tenido un contrato con otra compañía
durante 50 años
deberías preguntarles por qué hay falta
de oxígeno son una empresa multinacional
el mayor proveedor del mundo no había
razón para hacerle esto a nuestra ciudad
pronto serán las 7 de la tarde hora del
toque de queda rabia velina ha estado
esperando más de 8 horas no conseguirá
oxígeno para su padre esta noche
llegué a las 11 y me las arreglé para
conseguir una pipeta para salvar a mi
padre y a un amigo una experiencia
devastadora
[Aplausos]
experiencia devastadora
el gobernador de la región ha advertido
que hay que actuar rápidamente
autorizado tras semanas de suspenso la
vacuna china ha llegado por fin a la
capital amazónica esto en las noticias
buenas noches
[Música]